a lot has already been written about
Elon mus K he lives his life between the
tweets upended reinvented the Auto
industry Aerospace now trying it with
Twitter turned X
you spent two years shadowing him
what did you learn that we didn't
already know about Elon Musk well
there's certainly multiple Elon musk's
multiple personalities whether it's the
hardcore engineering mode that you know
so well where you can figure out how to
do a battery cell or more importantly
figure out how to do steps on an
assembly line that will make the Battery
South but also there's almost a demon
mode of Elon Musk so he turns really
dark and that can be very problematic
especially when it came to acquiring
Twitter which I think involves more
emotional intelligence for the ground
rules anything off limits did you sleep
on the factory floor next to him you
know I slept in Airstream trailers down
in the South Tip of Texas where SpaceX
has its launch pad I spent a lot of late
nights in factories he put nothing off
limits which surprised the heck out of
me I mean meetings that were about
forward-looking products everything else
he said I just want to surprise you
about the transparency in my side of the
deal was fine I want to be everywhere
but you get no control over the book you
don't even get to read it before it
comes out you've written a lot of books
Steve Jobs biography was maybe perhaps
an instant classic and in that book you
talk about the challenge of breaking
through the Apple co-founders reality
Distortion field with musk you had
extraordinary access I might count you
talk to more than 120 people around him
close deputies even family members his
father even
did you worry about that reality
Distortion field that he has the fact
that he can sometimes be an unreliable
narrator in his own life well yes he can
be unreliable and his memory is fallible
and he sort of cloaks himself as a hero
in every tale but I didn't feel a
reality Distortion field he was not he
almost was unaware of my presence it
seemed a lot of times because he'd be
being a real jerk to people at a meeting
or blow up on a walk around one of the
rocket sites and I think wait a minute
doesn't he know I'm taking notes here so
it did surprise me how open and in some
ways not trying to sugarcoat things he
was you spend a really significant part
of the book in the beginning talking
about his childhood and his relationship
with his father what was the early days
of Elon Musk like you know here's a
scrawny kid socially awkward beaten up
on the playground a whole lot went to a
Wilderness Camp in which you know sort
of survival and he lost 10 pounds in a
week because they kept beating him up
and taking his food but when he went
back to the Wilderness Camp a few years
later he had gotten bigger he learned a
little Judo and he said I just learned
to punch people in the nose as hard as I
could when they were being mean to me
and sometimes they'd beat me up but if I
punch them really hard in the nose they
wouldn't do it again you almost see that
nowadays which is he's pugnacious he
sometimes can be so confrontational and
when in doubt he punches in the nose you
talk about his relationship with his
father his father is almost described
like a Jekyll and hyde-like character
sometimes he can be friendly sometimes
he can be volatile I've never seen him
go so in depth about that childhood
experience why do you think he was ready
to talk about it now it took a long time
for musk to want to talked about his
childhood I just sat there I'd raise it
every now and then and sometimes we'd
get to a place where suddenly he'd start
talking about his father and he would go
and get teary-eyed at times very very
emotional and just say you don't know
how bad the abuse was and after a while
Elon just kept opening up about the
psychological scars he had when his
father would make him stand in front of
his father and yell at him for more than
an hour and take the sides of the people
who'd beaten up Elon and call Elon
stupid you write that the PTSD from his
childhood also instilled in him an
aversion to contentment what do you
think that means for the companies that
he runs what does that mean for the the
people that work for him as they try to
reach the goals and sometimes achieve
these goals he's addicted to drama he's
addicted to risk and whenever things
seem to be going smoothly he almost has
a compulsion to stir things up but
allows him to become a disruptive figure
but also a difficult leader what do you
think was one of the most surprising
kind of instances of him losing his
temper with one of his employees oh one
night in South Texas at the launch pad
of SpaceX it's a Friday night at 10 pm
and everything's going smoothly there's
no launches being scheduled and he looks
and there's only two people working at
the launch pad and all of a sudden I see
demon mode coming in almost like storm
clouds from the Gulf of Mexico and I'm
thinking well it's Friday night at 10 pm
and yet he just Reams out this guy named
Andy who was in charge of the launch pad
site and he orders a surge he orders a
hundred people to come in from different
parts of SpaceX from Florida California
so they can all work for 24 hours a day
getting this thing done even though
there was no need to what is demon mode
in your mind it's almost like Dr Jekyll
and Mr Hyde where a cloud comes over and
he gets into a trance and he can just be
tough in a cold way he never gets really
angry never gets that physical but
coldly brutal to people and he almost
doesn't remember afterwards what he's
done sometimes I'll say why did you say
that to that person and he'll look at me
blankly as if he didn't quite remember
what happened while he was in Demon mode
now one of the things that Claire
Boucher on his Grime says is you don't
want to be around him when he's in Demon
mode it's really frightening he said she
said but she eventually added but demon
mode is what gets done given all of
the stories about how he treats people
why do you think he still has the
ability to attract talent to his
companies I talked to some of the people
on the autopilot team at Tesla when they
were doing Optimus the robot and a
couple of them had quit because it was
just too brutal dealing with them and
they got burned doubt but then one of
them was back I said what happened he
said I decided I had a choice between
being burned out or being bored and I
decided I wanted to be burned out
because I believed in the mission so
some survived but a whole lot don't
another key one of the ways of how he
tries to manage or how he kind of tries
to think about the world is something he
calls first principles which is
essentially a problem-solving way to not
take what's been done in the past is the
way it should be done in the future is
trying to reach the ultimate goal of
whatever you're setting out kind of
getting to the root problem and figuring
out from there but that's very abstract
it's kind of hard to put that understand
what he means by that but it seems as if
by sitting around with him you've kind
of seen the way he's trying to impart
that decision-making framework to people
with something called the algorithm what
is the algorithm the algorithm is a
five-step process we're not only making
good products and designing good
products but manufacturing them and
you're right it begins with first
principles he says question every
requirement and by first principles he
means look down at the physics if
somebody says no we can't build it at
this Price He says tell me how much the
materials cost tell me exactly what's
involved here and then tell me you can
or can't do it when he first was trying
to buy a rocket booster in Russia early
on and they were charging him 15 million
dollars or something on the flight home
he calculated how much of the cost of
materials and Fuel and he said okay
those are the first principles so we
should be able to make it at a much
cheaper cost with the algorithm he's
always saying question every requirement
and then delete delete so he simplifies
things and then only then do you start
to speed up the manufacturing process
and eventually automate it one of his
big mistakes at Tesla was he went to
automation to quickly before he had
deleted every part and questioned every
requirement do you see him moving into a
new era where he's essentially seeding a
bunch of ideas almost a Thomas Edison
character putting money towards bigger
ideas and letting smart people invent it
or is he going to can I keep control
like a Henry Ford back in the day of of
making sure the Model T was the Model T
for as long as possible well I think one
of his weaknesses I'll call it is he
really is a control freak
you want them to give up control say of
Twitter you're thinking okay Linda
yaccarino should run it but he doesn't
really see too much control Gwen
Shotwell at SpaceX learns how to deal
with him he really is focused on the
product she gets to run the company but
no I don't see him giving up a lot of
control over these companies even though
they're now six or seven of them
depending on how you count that he's
running are we in the Final Act of this
kind of narrative uh or has he peaked is
he on the decline
um I would say that for many years
people have predicted his kind of the
Epic collapse of something and he's been
able to get through it is is this just
another example of that some of them are
going to collapse this can be like his
rocket chips and everything else he
believes you can't get into orbit
without blowing things up every now and
then so there will be debris there will
be things blown up but I think you know
most things he's done keep surprising me
as being successful